[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
y como a raza papada
tiene la misma
en tu mirada
pero te tengo que explicar un tanto
agite ya que me voy a cansar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero dónde
de contar a la gente cómo abordar la
mona vagina
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
qué
y siente su mirada en la diese la fiebre
[Música]
se busca pero cuando encuentras lo
quieres
dice que se lo llamas
o no
cuando cuando
[Música]
cuando quiera verme no voy a estar
ah
no olvides que dice que ilusiona mujer
dice que su mirada nadie
[Música]
el método para que entre la gente vamos
vamos adentro
qué manera de romper el hielo así de una
de pecho bien buenas tardes nosotros
somos arrastra como topadora y le vamos
a contar hola chicos pasen pasen
siéntense
les vamos a contar cuáles son los cuatro
momentos
y que nosotros consideramos
indispensables a la hora de armar un
show a la hora de pensar en esta lista
de las canciones
cuáles son los cuatro momentos que no
pueden faltar para que un show sea ideal
según nuestro criterio
uno de esos momentos es de que esté la
canción propia sí de darnos la
oportunidad de regalarles algo de
nuestra autoría algo nuevo que eso nos
realce la identidad también y nos
diferencia como esta canción que
arrancamos y se llama don juan y otro de
esos momentos es el momento de la
interacción con el público
entonces ese momento nos da les da vida
a la canción le parece si cantamos
juntos el estribillo no perdamos más
tiempo y vamos a ese momento donjuán por
cuatro y bailando todo el mundo
sería tomando cual tocando y ahora
[Música]
con un poquito más verdad
la última noche
[Música]
perfecto para menos ya se lo aprendieron
son unos grosores excelentes
ahora si consigo viste acá vos sabés
mucho y yo soy acá juego de local hoy
nada ni juega de local si viste y
sentado acá algún don juan siempre
siempre hay algunas aves y hasta hay más
de la mejor hay un montón pero si
tenemos que nombrar a uno vecino del
público cuáles uno del público les está
por este sector por este sector de
camisa no sé si la gente quiere irse
identificando color está de camisa
camisa blanca a cuadros a ver quién
cuantos
cuando cuando cantas
cuándo
[Música]
cuando quiera terminó cuando
cuando estás buscando
como tomadora
cuando se ha perdido
qué tal
[Música]
como la flor
tanto
me diste tú
se marchita
yo
yo se pierde
no me duele
[Música]
sí
cómo
de marte
[Música]
pero
[Aplausos]
ah
y
esta es la más dulce de la cumbia
[Música]
sí
d
[Música]
de muerte
sobre
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
y suena raza cómo mejorar
bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
no más
cómo
[Música]
ah
mira vamos para atrás
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tenía que llamar secreto me enamora da
respiro porque sé que no
[Música]
lo tuyo no es para mí pienso los
sentimientos
del infierno
porque no quiero nada
quiero saber
corazón
por ganar
pero nada
[Música]
porque tengo un corazón valiente voy a
quererte voy a quererte porque tengo el
corazón valiente prefiero amarte después
por verte porque tengo corazón también
te voy a tener que voy a hacer porque
tenemos cuáles son valientes prefiero a
marte
y después perder
[Aplausos]
[Música]
todo arriba vamos a bailar
me arrepiento de este amor que me cuesta
el corazón amarillo de mi boca jamás me
imaginé que la carne de tu que tuve
cuerpo me too hace que la vida se los
van día de hoy no volverá después de la
muerte
[Música]
tengamos
estamos muertas
d
bebiendo a este amor el que después su
corazón
m
después siento que la vida se nos va el
día de hoy no volverá
muchísimas gracias
[Música]
nosotros somos para razas como tomar
[Aplausos]
[Música]